jimmy ly was at last year's tiananmen
square rally in hong kong for just 15
minutes and did not address the crowd
the judge said prosecutors had been able
to prove he had incited others to attend
the vigil lai used to own apple daily a
vocal pro-democracy paper
the tabloid was shut down after police
raided its officers and arrested staff
under a national security law
some journalists in hong kong say they
are not surprised by wednesday's verdict
this has been the trend over the last
year the judge amanda woodcock ruled
that jimmy ly didn't have to say
anything uh to even incite her there's a
very fact that he turned up just outside
the park was quote a deliberate act to
rally support for and publicly spotlight
the unauthorized assembly
the judge also found barrister chao hong
tung and former reporter gwyneth ho
guilty of either taking part or inciting
others to join the event
all three pleaded not guilty
16 other activists are already serving
jail sentences for also taking part in
the commemoration
hong kong has traditionally held large
events on the anniversary of the teleman
crackdown in beijing
for the first time in 30 years police in
hong kong banned last year's rally
citing coronavirus restrictions
commemorations were also banned this
year
this case itself is part i would say
perhaps a wider crackdown on the memory
of the 1989 massacre textbooks have been
censored museum exhibits confiscated
the vigils organizers have been put
behind bars and as you can see this
commemoration
has been banned
last year's ban was imposed just as
china passed a sweeping national
security law in hong kong
activists say the latest convictions are
another example of hong kong's leaders
bowing to pressure from beijing to
censure pro-democracy expression
florence louis al jazeera